effortless
stoicism
James Pierce has written and spoken with
deep insight about what he calls
effortless stoicism
see here for some of those resources and
in the description to this video or
podcasts for links to his own writings
on the topic in one of his articles he
writes quote effortless stoicism does
not come when you have control of your
emotions but when you no longer need it
end quote stoicism is a school of
thought arising out of an attitude first
explained in ancient Greece by Xena of
cytium in around 300 BC and perhaps most
fully articulated in the writings of the
Roman Emperor Marcus Aurelius and is
itself a deep philosophy which I
encourage the listener or viewer to
explore but for our purposes now it is
enough to recognize that the term
stoicism today carries with it an
important remnant of the deep
philosophical tradition that lays behind
it namely that stoicism entails enduring
something patiently or not being
reactive emotionally in the moment to
something that happens to you being
thoughtful and considered in other words
being emotionally resilient we might say
in even more modern educational
psychological talk it seems as if such
an attitude would take a suppression of
feelings that it should take effort but
James explains how it can be otherwise
I encourage everyone as I said to read
James's blog on this and his thread on
Twitter and his videos about this he is
the originator of these powerful ideas
and in what I say that follows any
mistakes in interpretational emphasis
will of course be my own I'm simply
going to try to unpack effortless
stoicism a little in my own words and
explore what I think are the practical
applications and implications of some of
this as my own mind has been changed on
what I think should be emphasized on
some of these issues we'll come back to
that stoicism need not be about enduring
or suppressing instead as James explains
it can be about understanding outwardly
the same thing can be observed by any
external Observer of the so-called stoic
person namely there are kind of two
kinds of stoicism in this sense a person
who is actually actively suppressing
emotions compared to a person who is
better understanding their emotions in
both cases the person is seemingly not
caught up in the emotion of reacting in
the moment
but only in the former case where the
suppression is actually going on is the
internal subjective State one which
carries with it a kind of negativity at
times
anxiety fear and most importantly a loss
of one's clear train of thought
one is actually going with the emotion
but in a sense they're pretending not to
be that's that kind of false stoicism
the effortful stoicism but
understanding one's emotions better
means one has a better set of ideas that
constitute a good to them at least
explanation of reality and once they are
in possession of this they can accept
reality without reacting to that reality
in an unthoughtful way of course
reactions emotionally are both possible
and desirable of course they are we want
to defend ourselves if attacked or run
away if we're scared or jump with joy
when the wonderful thing happens but we
also want to be doing these things
consciously because then we are fully
present and have a deeper appreciation
of each emotion of the moment and of
reality next let me come to the main
part of my own thesis about this
effortless or even enlightened to
stoicism we might say is not just about
not fleeing the worst about escaping
from feeling bad about past mistakes
lost loves deep trauma and serious
coercion it's not merely about escaping
or fleeing from those kind of things
it's also about all practical day-to-day
things literally stuff as prosaic and
mundane as exercise
some people think they do not enjoy
doing exercise and yet they also know
that it's good for them must I coerce
myself through things I know on one
level at least are good for me but on
the other I feel as if I do not want to
do those things so here is where I
changed my mind about what I want to
emphasize about this
I haven't changed anything substantively
about what I think about the philosophy
of this as such of my philosophy of the
importance of motivation for example
none of that's changed but it is worth
bearing something in mind in addition to
what I have rather often advised to
people when it comes to this kind of
thing I used to say to people who
challenged me on exactly this they would
say things like well it's all right for
you Brett Hall because you've
Incorporated for example exercise into
your life and you've learned to enjoy it
long ago or you Brett Hall had good
Science and Mathematics teachers
apparently but I didn't and I was turned
off those subjects how can I learn to
exercise or learn mathematics and
science now if I don't enjoy any of that
even if I know they are good to know and
good to do what I used to say about all
this is well just try for a while get
over that coercion hump find the fun
now I've changed my perspective if not
my mind on this
I'm looking at it all from a different
angle with one Proviso I still concede
there are young people in genuine
extremists we might say those with major
depression at the end of their tether
who feel as if they contribute nothing
and mean nothing to anyone or anything
and don't know what to do next
these young people especially are truly
at risk as the terminology today goes
these youngsters but actually it can be
a person of any age are in a kind of
psychological emergency they need their
hand held and I still say to them if
they are not seeking help from others
right now and they should be then they
should just try some things out for a
while because if you speak to young
people like this they say but literally
nothing feels good nothing I have heard
this kind of thing from if not many then
certainly an uncomfortable number of
times I've heard it over the course of
my 20 plus years of working directly
with young people I would still say to
them absent everything else try out
exercising
for those people trying still is a
prescription just for a month every day
give it a go why because it's a simple
instruction when you just don't know how
to do anything else yet
you can at least just make that promise
to yourself
to try out exercise try out coding try
out mathematics try out some art try out
the dance or the Poetry or the rioting
or whatever it is you can find the fun
in something and sometimes you will find
a vein of Rich silver ore you will find
it and then realize it becomes
effortless to follow it so for those
people in those genuine times of
emergency I still do advise precisely
that to try especially if they fear to
seek help directly from others but they
should of course seek help
but now I would also say perhaps listen
to what James Pierce says on this and
what I'm about to say and see if this
works and for those not in an emergency
in a state of true mental anguish I will
say try the following instead of
temporary coercion of course the word
try here is actually perverse as we will
come to see in a moment after all this
all should be effortless if you're not
doing exercise or not doing something
else that you otherwise know is good for
you but it feels bad then that's just
because there is something there's
something about the world you do not
understand you need to understand your
ideas and reality and then you won't
feel bad about the good thing
why because if it's inherently good then
you can understand that and inherently
good things do not feel bad with
exercise you need to really understand
no no I mean really understand what is
happening here not just your feelings
you need to understand something deeper
than just your feelings you need to also
understand external reality better as
well
exercise for many people really will
mean the difference between life and
death or a long life and a short life or
a life of pain and suffering of the bad
kind versus a strong vibrant energetic
flexible no injury avoiding sickness
mentally and physically agile life if
you can understand this really
really understand it as a matter of it
Dawning on you the truth of all this the
importance and virtue of exercise you
will no longer see exercise as an effort
you will just see it as part of your
life a necessary need to move and the
more you see a need to move the more you
will move and the more vigorously you
might even begin adding weight to your
movements and begin pushing lumps of
Iron and Steel around a little room
something we call working out at a gym
and you won't regard any of it as really
hard work but rather an exciting and fun
thing to do because you'll understand
mentally and then your body will
understand
inexplicitly and give you feedback you
interpret not as painful but actually as
pleasurable and satisfying you will feel
excited before you go to the gym you'll
feel energized while you're there and a
sense of accomplishment
afterwards what more could you want
but people who regard it as all feeling
bad don't understand how any of that is
possible or they may have forgotten
temporarily they need to understand
reality as it is so now let's go beyond
exercise and emotional distress with
effortless stoicism because it literally
works for everything
come on you should be getting stuff done
and you should enjoy doing so why
because you've learned to because you
understand why you don't need to and
thus do not feel coerced or bad about
doing these good things that you really
want to do and you want to want to do
you need to live your life not merely
exist and it needs to be effortless it
needs to be fun and engaging as I hinted
at before people over the years have
asked me about not merely what maths and
physics to study for example what books
to buy or lectures to watch in order to
gain the knowledge to understand a
reality more deeply but also they've
asked me how to get past not enjoying it
because they find it boring what I've
said in the past is to try to push
through and see if after a month or so
you find the fun otherwise then drop it
I was wrong about that
at least I was wrong to put it precisely
that way
although as I say this attitude can
still work for some youngsters in
extremists who are deeply depressed and
say as they have said to me they
literally claim to find nothing fun the
spark of life has tragically gone out in
them far too soon in fact at any time in
your life this spark should never go out
it's always too soon
but I've said to those people who've
come to me experiment with life try a
few different things but okay that's an
exception these people in true deep
extremists
very depressed
but what about the person in their 20s
or 30s or 40s or 50s who wants to
understand quantum physics but
simultaneously finds it boring and dry
every time they pick up a textbook and
turn on a lecture well the reason you're
finding it boring and dry is because
there's something you do not understand
and I don't just mean about quantum
physics necessarily you need to
understand something about the reality
of the world that's holding you back you
need to become or you need to get or you
need to learn to be enlightened on this
at least and that should be as James
says effortless Enlightenment should be
an all-round Universal thing there in
every moment for the truly enlightened
yes indeed but for now let's focus on
the specific point but for example doing
maths or physics or just learning any
old thing you want to that seem unable
to find enjoyable effortless stoicism
here might involve the enlightenment of
coming to realize how understanding for
example quantum physics might require
you to realize how important it is to
the world maybe that can be enough maybe
that can be the motivation and that can
be your aha moment of realizing wow this
subject is just so important to the
world and therefore I'm excited about
learning it maybe that can be the
problem that you want to solve that you
want to make progress on something that
is important for the world as well as
important for you so realizing that that
could be your aha moment but personally
I doubt it you need to find a better
hook than that a problem that animates
you personally scientifically for
example and this process of finding that
thing in an effortless way may result in
you doing quantum physics
or it may not in the latter case where
you may not you may realize you
understand reality truly better now
namely that now you really do get it you
get why you don't get quantum physics
but instead you get why trying to do
quantum physics or anything else that
you don't really feel like you're
enjoying you come to understand
trying to want to do that thing all
along was wrong for you it was the wrong
path you've come to understand that
reality this reminds me of Naval and
nevy's advice on getting rich they have
explained how you'll never get there
you'll never get rich relying on a
salary on renting out your time people
often hear that that part of their
advice and they kind of understand it
but only partially Naval and Nivea are
not saying they're not saying never rent
out your time never rely upon a salary
or a wage they're not saying renting out
your time is inherently bad that somehow
you're a lesser person if you're on a
wage or a salary no they're not saying
that at all they are saying it's not the
path to Financial Freedom that's just
reality Financial Freedom here meaning
you never have to worry about your
finances basically ever again with
Financial Freedom your money is working
for you and you can live where you want
more or less and drive what you want if
you want and travel where you want when
you want and give your children what
they want when they want it what Nevada
Nivea are saying is you can't have all
of that all of that kind of freedom on a
wage or a salary by renting out your
time in particular because your time is
not your own you're renting it out to
someone else but but and the bud is just
so important here Naval and nivi quickly
followed up with when you're starting
out you may need to rent out your time
but the only excuse for that is when
you're starting out so when you're
starting out your options are very
limited by the Limited funds you have
and it's just a necessary stage that
many people have to go through you can't
deny a reality you don't have the money
right now to do whatever it is that you
want like a genuinely rich person does a
rich person a truly wealthy person is
defined by having the money to basically
do whatever they want they're not
worried about getting by day to day and
week to week those concerns about bills
for example have literally vanished from
their minds it's all automated the home
electricity bill not something I look
twice at perhaps they never look at it
because some service now takes care of
all of their bills it's beneath them and
not worth their time to look at at how
much their phone bill is this month just
looking at it costs more than their time
is worth you're denying reality if you
say that this is not something that you
want for yourself this is where we all
want to be and ideally where we all
should be but we can't be there by
renting out our time so how do we get
there well you can either coerce
yourself temporarily through that phase
that might have been what I said
previously coerce yourself through the
time of earning a wage or earning a
salary by renting a Time
or or
understand and effortlessly find the
stoicism I think I'd say the latter now
more often it's what James Naval and
Nivea are saying understand reality and
then it will be effortless
get a wage or a salary save your money
and then get to a place where you can do
this this being number one understand
why it's necessary for now
to have that wide your salary and enjoy
it and two get to a place where you no
longer need it the wage or the salary
and therefore get rich get financially
enlightened to a degree win the
financial lottery in a sense and then
begin to get fully enlightened in other
words when the full Lottery of Life
realize it's all here already whatever
you want is literally here in the
physical Universe at least in the
Multiverse and in the mental space of
ideas it's there in the possibility
now you just have to construct it
construct reality around you what it
takes is understanding recognizing in
the moment what it is you really desire
what your preferences are what you feel
that means not reacting in the moment
and not feeling terrible about reality
and terrible about your circumstances it
means instead understanding it and that
is an unending process you can become
more and more enlightened more deeply
aware of reality in the moment
everything is like this yes everything
all understanding it's all improvable
with better ideas oh so you've learned
Newtonian physics so you think you
understand physics now do you it's all
common sense it's just logic you get it
you get what relative velocity is and
time and space and cause and effect and
so on
oh hold on a minute now suddenly all
that gets upended because you just
learned that special and general
relativity are things aha so now you
think you get it you understand physics
more deeply oh but wait a moment quantum
theories also apparently a thing well
now now you get it no wait wait the
Multiverse is a thing now you get it no
weight you've just read Shadows chapter
2 of the fabric of reality and now you
understand that that's a way of
understanding the Multiverse and
therefore quantum theory okay maybe you
get it now no wait wait fungibility and
chapter 10 of the beginning of infinity
they are things
now now maybe you get physics no you
realize there are levels to getting it
ever deeper understandings that never
terminate in finality this was my
trajectory with all of that
even even with counting I should say
something as simple as counting that
everyone learns on mother's knee yes
even that is infinitely deep there's an
infinite well of mystery to explore here
there's ever greater depth to dig and
more fundamentals to find how can
something so simple like counting be
infinitely deep
does one plus one equals two have
infinite depth beyond that surface truth
yes it does for example you can learn to
prove that one plus one equals two from
something called the axioms Pino's
axioms it takes a full page of proof in
order to prove this and when I first
encountered this I thought wow now I
finally have an understanding of basic
arithmetic that I never had before
I'm more fully understood one plus one
equals two and then I figured out after
reading David Deutsch on this that that
kind of proof is actually a physical
process and then I realized wait all
physical things can be represented as
computations of a kind I I then
understood that all computations are
error prone and and you're thinking my
thinking everyone's thinking is a kind
of error-prone computation therefore we
are all inherently fallible we can all
always misunderstand
and then then you can begin to realize
you arrive back at the original Insight
from David Deutsch and now James as well
more deeply and now wait once more
wait and realize that this will continue
happening Forever on everything if you
and I are willing to understand
everything more deeply and realize there
always is a deeper way to understand
things
and it's all thrilling
I don't need to react in the moment
reality just is and can always be more
deeply understood if it feels super bad
or super good
understanding can help me appreciate
those Sensations more deeply and I need
not get carried away by them but rather
be present in the moment and aware and
in a sense be in awe of what is not
fearful or hopeful of what might be but
rather because being present here and
now and understanding things more deeply
means I can change things
ideas are mine to create
and when I create a better explanation
I can transform the world